I was thinking about your acting career
you kind of uh blew off a big
opportunity
this was the time when Mad Men I'm just
saying I have terrible instincts like
when Mad Men happened I was friends with
Jon Hamm he played a cable guy on the
Sarah Silverman program right so then he
called me and he's like hey I'm doing
this pilot on AMC you should audition
for it and I said uh uh I'm not gonna
audition for a pilot on AMC like I was
laughing that's that old movie channel
well you were even even more out right
you said to him listen I've got my own
TV show why do I have to go audition for
Tommy Central yeah go [ __ ] off and then
oh I remember getting the script um I
mean these aren't offers or anything but
like my agent sent me the script for um
bridesmaids and I just read the title
and was like [ __ ] this
braids made and now that's probably my
I've seen that like 15 times
do you are you filled with regret when
something like that happens when you
don't you don't you don't dwell on it
watch bridesmaids and go oh I should
have played this part of this part I
just watch it and I love it like I die
laughing every time and uh I remember
when I first came out like when I first
was working the pilot for friends was
floating around the uh script I heard
you were sort of offered something in
French 100 no no I was I was too young I
was younger but um I remember the script
going around and crying laughing at how
dumb the title was
that a problem sometimes when you're a
very smart comedian that you that you're
almost too hip for the room and every
everything is kind of silly and stupid
like friends is stupid oh I'm not good
at bridesmaid oh I'm not gonna go on AMC
like it's almost like you're too smart
being my favorite thing right
all right